Here we are in our
RollViewController.swift file.
And the first thing I want you to
do is delete any code that's in
the rollTheDice method.
Here in this method, we're going to
present our custom view controller.
So how are we going to do that?
We might as well start by trying
to present it the same way we did
the UI Kit view controllers.
So in that case, we just construct our
DiceViewController and then present it.
But also we need to
set those dice values.
So we'll do that in these two lines.
Okay, let's see if it runs.
Okay, so far, so good.
Mm, got a problem.
What does the console say?
Okay, fatal error, unexpectedly found
nil while unwrapping an optional value.
Okay, so the green highlighting is
pointing to the first die property,
and we know if the first
type property is nil,
that's going to cause a runtime error.
Because firstDie is an implicitly
unwrapped optional.
So why is firstDie nil?
If we look back at our object diagram,
we're reminded that these outlets to
our views were created in storyboard.
We created this instance of
DiceViewController without storyboard.
So that means these outlets, these
views, and this action don't exist yet.
So that's a problem.
So in order to get rid of this error,
we need to get a fully assembled
DiceViewController from storyboard.
So let's close the console and
then go back into our
RollViewController.swift file.
So here's where we were presenting
our DiceViewController before in
the rollTheDice method.
You go ahead and delete this reference
to the DiceViewController, and
we're going to replace it.
In this line, first we get
a reference to a storyboard object.
And then we asked for
the DiceViewController by name,
using its storyboard identifier.
Let's take a closer look
at this new method,
instantiateViewControllerWithIdentifier.
This identifier is just a string.
It's the name that you give
the view controller in storyboard.
So let's double check that we
actually set that name in storyboard.
So if I open up the storyboard file and
click on the DiceViewController,
I can look in the Utilities pane and
click on the Identity Inspector.
In the Identity Inspector, right here
you'll see the storyboard identifier.
And we can see that, yes, indeed,
it is set to Dice View Controller.
Just for kicks, I'm going to go ahead
and delete this storyboard ID and
the class ID and
see what would happen if you forgot to
put the name of the view controller.
Now let's try and run it.
Okay, so it compiles fine.
Roll the dice.
Uh-oh, terminating with
uncaught exception.
Okay, so if you get one of
these exception errors,
what you want to do is scroll
up to the top of the console.
And then you'll get more
information about the error.
In here we can see, storyboard
doesn't contain a view controller with
identifier DiceViewController.
So that's pretty much what we expected.
But we know how to fix that.
We'll just go back in storyboard and
reset the name.
There, that ought to do it.
Now let's go back into our
RollViewController.swift file.
Because I want to point out
one more thing about that
instantiateViewControllerWithIdentifier
method.
What's going on at the end of
this line here where it says,
DiceViewController as
DiceViewController.
If you Alt+click on this method,
you can see that it returns any object.
That's why we need to cast that returned
object as a DiceViewController.